oui j'ai fait n'importe quoi et je
vivais clairement audessus de mes moyens
et et surtout pour rien pour en fait je
me suis dit mais pourquoi pour
impressionner qui pour faire passer quel
message à qui ça pour faire le kké et
sortir dans des restos et dans des trucs
et voilà je l'ai fait je le regrette en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partie Philippe Vardon on en parlait
tout à l'heure euh souhaite déposer
plainte contre complément en enquête
parce qu'il dit ne jamais avoir tenu ses
propos c'est fou parce que c'est ce
qu'il a dit euh regardez voici près d'un
an j'ai été contacté par un journaliste
de complément d'enquête écoutez bien ce
tweet qu'il a publié aujourd'hui
Philippe Vardon écoutez bien parce que
là il peut pas avoir que des gens qui
disent n'importe quoi non plus c'est ce
qui est fou c'est parce que complément
d'enquête tout ce qui disent eux c'est
on doit le prendre pour argent content
et tout ce qui est dit contre eux ce
sont des bêtises et ce sont de de
fausses infos il a tweeté je pense pas
que ce garçon euh a envie de de de si si
c'était pas vrai je pense pas qu'il
aurait tweeté an voici près d'un an j'ai
été contacté par un journaliste de
complément d'enquête lors d'une
rencontre je lui ai fait part de mon
refus catégorique de participer de
quelque manière que ce soit à ce
reportage contre Jordan Bardella
d'ailleurs il dit contre Jordane
Bardella n pas sur Jordane Bardella donc
chacun sait que j'ai c-irigé la campagne
en 2019 puisque l'équipe de complément
d'enquête prétend que j'aurais donné un
accord j'ai chargé mon avocat d'étudier
des poursuites pour me convaincre de
participer au reportage et faire
pression sur moi ce journaliste a menacé
de diffuser une vidéo largement connue
il a près de 30 ans désormais j'avais 15
ans sur laquelle j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de m'expliquer d'exprimer mes profonds
regrets et qui ne correspond en rien à
l'homme qui s'est bâti depuis et que je
suis aujourd'hui minable oui carrément
ce doit être la fameuse déontologie du
service public audiovisuel j'imagine
donc ils ont fait du
chantage Jacques cardos vous qui avez
travaillé là-bas est-ce que c'est
possible ça c'est incroyable ça je dis
ça aujourd'hui me n si c'est vrai c'est
extrêmement grave parce il y a quelque
chose qu'on a pas dit sur l'anonyme
euh chaque journaliste travaille avec sa
conscience mais normalement lorsque tu
produis une interview anonyme il faut
pouvoir avoir la preuve quand même au
cas où il y a un procès de dire bah
c'est anonyme sauf que moi j'ai
quelqu'un donc si vous portez plainte
contre moi je vais divulguer mes
identités moi personnellement je
travaille comme ça c'estàd que si je
produis de l'anonyme ça veut dire que
derrière j'ai des j'ai j'ai les
identités des gens tu comprends ce que
je veux dire vous le savez y a des si
jamais c'est totalement faake alors là
c'est extrêmement grave les gens non non
c'est pas ça Vardon on en pense qu'on
veut là on parle pas de Vardon on parle
des méthodes voilà je vois des gens qui
disent oui
Vardon Vardon est un as et oui mais on a
pas dit qu'on on a pas dit qu'on adhéit
aux idées de de Vardon on disait juste
que Vardon dénonce les vidéos voilà et
donc il y a des gens qui disent oui mais
c'est c'est les gars c'est pas on
dénonce pas la personne on dénonce les
méthodes voilà aujourd'hui c'est ça
qu'on fait donc apparemment il il
l'aurait il aurait il aurait fait du
chantage ben c'est extrêmement grave si
c'est ça cy si c'est ça c'est extr comm
si c'est pas vrai complément d'enquête
ils ont mais là en tous les cas il a
tout intérêt à porter plainte parce que
et eux à l'attaquer si excusez-moi ça
commence à faire beaucoup c'estd que
chaque personne qui témoigne dans le
reportage l'une porte plainte l'autre a
dit en fait j'ai jamais dit que Barnel
était derrière le T c'est ça sunit comme
ça en fait chaque personne les anonymes
on reviennent pas sur les déclar donc
alors il y a un autre extrait euh Jordan
euh je je suis obligé de le mettre c'est
c'est on c'est c'est le vos liens
supposé avec des militants d' l'extrême
droite violent et nazi qu'est-ce que
vous dites à ça
mais avec qui c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
dans le la grande tante de ma cousine
qui connait la boulangère
grand sous la bannière du GUD un
groupuscu raciste antisémite et violent
des centaines de militants d'extrême
droite paragou dans les r de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Paris
dans les rangs Axel Lousteau un vieux
copain de la patron son ancien
trésorier alors Jordan qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça d'abord il d'abord ce
que je trouve malhonnête c'est qu'après
cette manifestation du Gude et et ils
auraient pu avoir l'honnêteté de passer
l'extrrait j'ai demandé la
dissolution de tous les groupusculle
d'extrême droite y compris celui qui
manifestait ici deuxièmement Axel
Loustau euh a été prestataire de service
pour le rassemblement national la
dernière fois qu'il a eu une prestation
de service avec le rassemblement
national c'était en
2017 donc je veux bien qu'on tourne
autour du pot mais moi c'est pas mes
idées c'est pas ma tendance et c'est pas
ma manière de faire de la politique donc
encore une fois on me reproche d'être
dans un parti qui à un moment donné a eu
un lien avec une personne qui était
actionnaire d'un d'une société de
communication qui s'est retrouvé à cette
cette manifestation si on fait ça pour
tous les actionnaires de tous les
prestataires de toutes les chaînes de
télé et de tous les partis politiques
franchement on va en apprendre quand au
Gude il y a des gens qui ont été au Gude
quand ils étaient plus jeunes mais il y
en a dans tous les mouvements politiques
et il y a même des gens notamment à
droite qui sont devenus ministres comme
Monsieur Longuet qui lui a participé du
G quand il était jeune qui a eu un
engagement radical quand il était jeune
et qui est devenu ministre de la
République
française voilà si vous voulez point
final je n'ai pas de lien en fait avec
cette avec cette idéologie avec cette
mouvance
le complément d'enquête on va dire un
dernier mot dessus aujourd'hui mais
juste il y a quelques Mo vous étiez sur
ce plateau face à Gabriel Atal devenu
premier ministreou on avait parlé à
l'époque de duel des dauphins pensez
quoi de sa
nomination moi je le jugerai à ce qu'il
fera d' voilà c'est que j'ai j'ai de la
considération personnelle pour pour lui
bien ce ne sont pas mes idées on a eu
l'occasion de faire beaucoup de débats
ensemble maintenant je crains que rien
ne change vous avez rencontré
aujourd'hui j'ai été reçu à matigon
aujourd'hui alors il vous a dit quoi
alors c'est il a le complément d'enquête
ou pas hein il aé complment alors on a
pas parlé du complément d'enquête en
revanche moi je lui ai parler de d'une
chose qui m'a paraît très important
c'est que le 1er février le gouvernement
a prévu d'augmenter les tarifs de
l'électricité de 10 % et je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui ont
du mal à boucler les fins de mois sûr et
je lui ai demandé solennellement de
renoncer à cette augmentation des prix
de l'électricité parce que je pense que
ça serait la goutte de trop pour
beaucoup de familles françaises dit quoi
et pour nos chefs d'entreprise dit ok il
m'a donné rendez-vous à son discours de
politique général don rendev 10
peut-être qu'on se retrouvera dans 10
ans mais et j'ai l'impression et moi
aussi je l'aime bien en plus vous aimez
bien quand même Gabriel Atal vous
l'aimez bien en tant que person mais si
vous voulez j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
rancœur ou de haine personnelle c'est on
peut ne pas avoir les mêmes idées
politiques et se
resp Mo mais non mais c'est pareil à
chaque fois que je viens chez vous avec
Gilber AC Gill Verdet c'est toujours
très compliqué mais mais humainement
j'ai pas de difficulté à discuter avec
vous c'est ça qui fait la richesse de la
démocratie don donc Gabriel Atal c'est
c'est pas mes idées mais je le respecte
comme personne je combattrai
politiquement mais ça m'empêche pas de
le respecter et c'est vrai avec tout le
monde d'ailleurs le sectarisme on le
fait que le subir nous c'est je suis pas
la France insoumise merci ça fait du
bien merci allez faire un tour avec Gill
verd il va vous présenter des amis juste
Jordan Bard un dernier mot sur
compliment d'enquête alors c'est quoi
c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien c'est
quoi vous attendeiez vous attendeiez à
pire vous attendeiez à mieux vous
attendeiez à quoi de bah tout ça pour ça
c'est ça mais maintenant vous êtes
tranquille vous savez que l'avantage
c'est qu'on me trouvera pas une
casserole dans 10 ans quoi ah bah ça
c'est sûr un an être lasérisé je pense
que là à priori très bien je su clean
bon vous êtes content
alors content non demain je vais en
déplacement je serai à côté de nos
agriculteursah je peux vous mettre g
veris avec vous venezoup peu de terrain
surtout un vrai mouvement de colère chez
les agriculteurs agriculteurs
dis vraiment vraiment vraiment sout les
agriculteurs depuis très ser demain et
ben
allez-y 2005 c'était c'était en 2005
donc j'étais dans l'appartement je
rencontre pour la première fois de ma
vie Yanis donc on est en 2024 donc 2005
il a quel âge Yanis 35 bah là je crois
qu'elle a 35 si vous faites les calculs
en plein
d il avait 15 ans 15 ans donc tu rends
compes alors donc toi tu étais
colocataire en fait non fa petit ami de
la colocataire de de de la c'était en
fait la propriétaire de l'appartement et
elle faisait une souslocation avec Bruno
qui était là mais Bruno tu le connaisais
il avait il faisait partie de popstar à
l'époque oui pas de ma saison mais de la
saison d'avant tu connaissais ou pas du
tout je le connaissais parce que je
l'avais déjà croisé sur les plateaux
télé de divertissement d' M6 donc il
faisait les il chorégraphia les
divertissements à l'époque de de de la
chaîne et et donc voilà moi je l'ai
rencontré et c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontré ma petite amie en fait et en
fait la première fois que je rencontre
Yanis Marshall c'était entre août et
septembre
2005 et je suis dans cet appartement là
je dis tiens c'est marrant il y a un
jeune dans le salon c'est qui et donc ma
copine de l'époque me dit dit c'est
Yanis je te le présente c'est vrai qu'il
avait il était un peu fou fou et je
m'aperçois que c'était le petit ami de
Bruno et donc à ce moment-là je me dis
ok bon c'est cool
euh il s'est passé ce qui s passé ils
allaient au resto il ils avaient une
vraie relation amoureuse incroyable et
et donc donc quand j'ai entendu
l'histoire de Yanis je me suis un petit
peu renseigné donc j'ai essayé de voir
un petit peu si tout concordait et euh
quand j'ai entendu l'avocat de de pour
une vendelli dire que c'était en 2007
c'est pas vrai en fait c'était vraiment
en 2005 et quand j'ai rencontré la
première fois Yanis c'était pas une
romance qui avait commencé à Paris elle
avait commencé auparavant en gros
l'histoire avait commencé à Cann d'après
ce que j'avais compris de ce que me
disait ma petite amie de l'époque elle
me disait écoute par contre il faudra
être discret sur sur le fait que Yanis
soit là parce qu'en fait il a pas
vraiment droit d'être ici euh parce qu'
en fait la mère de Yanis est contre
cette relation d'accord ah ouais donc
voilà et il revenait de il revenait à
l'époque de de Miami et je pense que
c'est la mère j'en suis même sûr c'est
que c'est parce que ma petite amie de
l'époque m'avait dit exactement ne dis
rien faut que tu sois vraiment discret
là-dessus je je m'étais pas posé de
question en fait je à l'époque j'étais
pas allé voir Yanis pour lui dire
dis-moi tu as quel âge j'ai voilà je
l'ai laissé vivre leur histoire d'amour
il avait l'air d'avoir 15 ans ou il
paraissait non il avait une petite mache
il était comme tous les danseurs en fait
ce qui est compliqué à l'époque c'est
que je me vois mal aller voir Bruno et
dire dis-moi ton petit copain il a quel
âge là parce que ça me paraît bizarre
voilà et moi j'étais là j'étais là
occasionnellement en fait mais mais
toutes les fois où j étais il était
là je connais bien Yanis parce que moi
je je l'ai rencontré en 2005 et je
sentais que dans leur relation il y
avait euh une emprise parce que c'était
déjà ça tu peux pas ça c'est toi qui le
dis pe pas savoir dit mais c'était son
prof de danse quoi ou voilà c'était son
prof de danse prof d'autoécole j'avais
pas il avait pas non pris moi mais oui
mais non mais voilà non mais non mais
donc là il faut pas dire tout est voilà
il faut quand même voilà on sait
pas regard de la loi c'est des choses
qui sont importantes qu exactement oui
mais on n pas la loi i c'est bien de le
préciser bon je tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que quand son avocat dit que il
avait rencontré qui qu'il avait qu'il
entretenait une relation en 2007 c'est
pas vrai il a rencontré Yanis à Cann moi
quand rencontré Yanis à Paris c'est
Bruno qui lui payit ses billets d'avion
donc il il venait par le par le billet
de de de Bruno il restait 3 qu jours à
la maison donc il se passait ce qui se
passait et c'était pas des relations
amicales hein donc on va pas se mentir
c'est pas il jouait pas au scrabble quoi
voilà tout simplement Bruno était était
à Paris lui oui éta à Paris voilà et
selon toi combien d'années avant le le
jour où tu l'as vu ils avaient déjà une
relation en fait parce que ça se joue à
à peu mais là au regard de la loi sil
avait 15 ans il il avait quel âge quand
tu l'as rencontré alors moi je va pas
posé la question de son âge he parce que
je voulais pas me dansireis la
date il avait 15 ans sauf que s'ils se
sont rencontrés 2 ans avant ces 15 ans
ça change au regard de la loi absolument
mais ils se connaissaiit déjà avant
vraiment avant parce qu' con mais est-ce
que la
relation moi c'est ce que moi de ce que
j'ai vu je vais être factuel moi j'ai vu
y à l'appartement en 2005 d'accord après
ce que dit Yanis c'est qu'il a rencontré
Bruno à 13 ans qu'il était à l'école à
14 ans et que sa première relation
sexuelle est arrivée selon le reportage
le jour de la fête des mères donc en
2000 en 2004 donc il avait 14 ans il
avait 14 ans ou ouais c'est fou he donc
voilà qu'est-ce que tu as dit Yanis tu
l'as eu ce weekend j'ai eu Yanis euh il
il comptait sur moi parce que il en
avait marre d'entendre les gens dire que
il avait av besoin de lumière que parce
qu'il s'était fait virer de la Stara que
il avait besoin de rester sous les feux
du des projecteurs mais en fait je veux
juste dire aux gens au haters qui
commencent à lui tomber dessus Yanis
avait pas besoin de la
staraavant il était déjà connu il avait
fait le tour du monde et que euh euh
s'il fait ça maintenant c'est qu'il en a
besoin il a besoin de se reconstruire
étatunis là il est en Australie ah
d'accord il est en Australie et il donne
des cours voilà mais ça lui tenait à
cœur de de de de de crever l'absé on va
dire voilà il avait besoin d'en
parler aujourd'hui déjà pourquoi vous
avez accepté et pourquoi vous avez
décidé de de de réagir sur cette affaire
mais parce que hier j'ai regardé enfin
en fait en fait je regarde tout oui je
regarde tout je suis sa maman je regarde
tout bien sûr c'est norm voilà mais hier
j'ai
regardé j'ai regardé votre émission
merci il y avait la jolie blonde je sais
pas votre nom excuse-moi Kelly Kelly qui
a posé une question à au jeune homme qui
est venu témoigner oui qui est le qui
est Lionel et oui voilà là et qui lui a
demandé
euh il a posé la question et qui lui a
dit mais quel âge avais Yanis oui non
mais moi je viens sur le plateau déjà
pour préciser l'âge Yanis avait 13 ans
et demi 14 ans pas plus question donc
voilà
euh après bon ce ce jeune homme était
était très sympa il a témoigné en faveur
de Yanis mais après d'entendre des gens
qui font des suppositions qui disent
tout n'importe quoi et quand j'entends
qu'on se permet de parler de moi sans
savoir là je dis stop bien sûr vous avez
bien raison je dis stop parce
que à un moment donné il a dit euh il
est là il est là oui bonsoir un moment
donné vous avez
dit la maman de Yanis n'était pas
d'accord non la maman de Yanis
c'était quand on est normalement
constitué on ne peut pas être d'accord
c'est quasiment impossible donc le mot
d'accord il est inapproprié pour moi il
est complètement inapproprié moi quand
j'ai découvert le potau rose puisque
j'ai découvert ça sur le téléphone de
mon fils en
2004 fin juin 2004 ce sont des dates que
je ne peux pas oublier ce sont des faits
que je ne peux pas oublier euh
d'ailleurs je commençais à avoir des
soupçons aussi sujet de ce monsieur
Bruno Vandelli qui ne ferait pas de mal
à un animal mais qui ferait du mal à des
enfants il peut porter plainte contre
moi pour diffamation j'en ai absolument
rien
àirer parce que tout ce que je dis ici
c'est la vérité tout ce que je dis ce
soir j'en ai j'ai toujours les
preuves je savais très bien que T tôt ou
tard cette histoire elle allait finir
par éclater pour tout vous dire je
l'espéis ah ça fait 20 ans que je
l'espère
et quand j'ai entendu son avocat dire
Yan ça fait un mois un mois qu'il parle
de ça un mois qu'il parle de ça non ça
fait 20 ans qu'on parle de ça envie de
lui répondre et quand j'entends un
avocat qui vient dénigrer quelqu'un qui
a subi mon fils a subi bon ben alors non
je me Terai plus quoi c'est fini au
contraire moi je suis très très fière de
du courage que mon fils a en ce moment
par qu'il a des nombreux il a de
nombreux témoignages et de nombreuses
personnes qui lui envoient des messages
et qui lui demande de faire quelque
chose de par sa
notoriété malheureusement ça fonctionne
comme
ça parce que il y il y a quand même eu
après moi il y a quand même eu pas mal
de plaines pas mal de mains de mains
courantes qui n'ont pas abouti parce
qu'il faut dire aussi je sais pour
revenir à vous quand vous disiez la
maman était pas d'accord non j'étais
dans la panique la plus totale j'étais
dans l'horreur la plus totale j'ai tue
cette histoire à toute ma famille
personne n'est au courant d'ailleurs où
j'habite à valoris tout le monde doit
tomber de haut personne n'était au
courant j'ai caché cette histoire pour
protéger mon
enfant la première des choses que j'ai
faites quand j'ai découvert les messages
sur le le téléphone portable de mon
enfant c'est d'appeler Bruno Vandelli et
je peux pas oublier quand je l'ai eu au
téléphone il s'est mis à pleurer en me
disant en utilisant la pitié en me
disant que sa mère venait de sa
grand-mère venait de
mourir sincèrement j'en avais rien àer
hein voilà et donc quand j'ai vu dans
l'état où était mon enfant parce que ce
qu'il faut dire ce qui a été le plus
difficile pour moi c'est de de ne pas
pouvoir porter plainte contre ce
monsieur ouais parce que j'avais en face
de moi j'avais un enfant qui était
complètement
euh comment comment on dit
euh dévasté non il é il était
sousemprise il était sous une emprise
totale une emprise qui était effrayante
de Bruno Vandelli quand vous avez un
enfant de 13 ans qui se tort par terre
et qui vous supplie de pas porter
plainte à cette époque Bruno Vandelli
était connu il passait sur M6 popstar
oui il était connu donc moi je me disais
mon Dieu je vais pas mettre mon fils est
trop jeune pour aller pour se retrouver
devant le feu médiatique les tout ça de
par la notoriété de Bruno à l'époque
euh c'était extrêmement difficile donc
la seule solution j'ai quand même été
voir un avocat Cann et qui m'a dit bah
qu'il fallait porter plainte mais vous
aviez en face de vous un enfant qui
disait ben je dis je NIR et
tout qui était je vous dis sous son
emprise mais totale
totale c'était comme si vous aviez
affaire à à quelqu'un qui est dans une
secte et qui et et que et que vous
essayez de sortir de son gourou c'est
exactement pareil je sais même pas voir
pire je sais pas donc moi la seule
solution que j'ai trouvé c'est que bah
c'était d'éloigner mon enfant l'AV
envoyé aux États-Unis c'est ça donc j'ai
éloigné mon enfant j'ai appelé une amie
d'enfance qui vivait à Pensacola
marieclaude d'ailleurs qui est prête à
témoigner aujourd'hui sans aucun
problème et qui s'est déplacé d'ailleurs
que je remercie qui a fait le voyage des
États-Unis jusqu'en France pour venir
reprendre mon
enfant et on l'a protégé comme ça et il
a été à l'école il a été scolarisé à
l'âge de 14 ans et j'ai les preuves j'ai
les documents j'ai les attestations des
écoles il était scolarisé aux États-Unis
à l'âge de 14 ans et
demi donc les faits ne se sont pas
passés quand il avait 16 ans l'âge
répond à son avocat ce n'est pas une
mascarade la mascarade c'est son client
et la mascarade c'est que toutes les
personnes autour de Bruno Vandelli
étaient au courant ouais toutes et dans
ce milieullà tout le monde était au
courant par contre ce que vous avez dit
hier de ce qui s'est passé en 2005 à
Paris je n'étais pas au courant je l'ai
découvert hier parce que si je l'avais
su qu'au retour des États-Unis il y
avait eu ça je peux vous garantir que
j'aurais pas fait de cadeau
ouais donc là vous avez bien dit hier il
fallait pas que la maman le sache et
exactement je l'ai appris
hier après euh je voudrais pas défendre
mon enfant parce que je suis pas
toujours d'accord avec Yanis moi tout
tout tous ces réseaux sociaux cette
façon de s'exposer Instagram tout ça
c'est pas du tout mon
truc mais quand même ça fait déjà depuis
à peu près une quinzaine d'années qu'on
en parle avec Yanis où il veut porter
plainte où il veut pas où il veut o il
veut pas il veut il se
rétracte s reculé pour mieux sauter quoi
ça ça fait des années que c'est comme ça
et ça lui a provoqué des crises de
panique ouais voilà donc moi aujourd'hui
bon même si ça me ça
remue je suis dans un sale état euh
parce que je suis pas très bien de de de
me remémorer tout ce qui s'est passé
mais euh quelque part je savais très
bien qu'un jour ou l'autre ça allait
éclater la vérité il faut qu'elle éclate
qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a éclaté
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a poussé
Yanis à mais il il a eu beaucoup de de
de de de de témoignages aussi d'autres
enfants d'accord et ont subit la même
chose et et qui qui qui qui dont les
parents ont d'ailleurs essayer de porter
plainte ou que ça ou que ce qui les
plaintes sont restées sans suite
d'ailleurs je demande à ses parents de
de de se rapprocher de moi puisque moi
euh Bruno Vandelli ne m'a jamais fait
peur d'ailleurs il le sait très bien
hein et je voudrais aussi euh j'en
profite pour être à la télé pour dire à
Bruno que qu'il oublie pas le message
que j'ai découvert sur le téléphone de
mon fils I'm slave for
you tout ça j'ai tout gardé
Bruno
donc on n'écrit pas des choses comme ça
à un enfant de 13 ans et
demi ça veut dire quoi déjà ah je suis
ton esclave non esclave c'est ça donc
mais moi j'avais déjà des c'est une
chanson de de Britney Spears ouais mais
moi j'avais déjà des doutes j'avais déjà
des doutes en
entre avril et mai 2004 puisqu'il était
insistant il voulait absolument que mon
enfant aille avec lui en stage de
formation si ma mémoire est bonne à mot
et là j'étais catégorique je disais non
hors de question comme on avait déjà été
avec son papa on l'avait déjà accompagné
dans un stage de formation à mot donc je
trouvais ça bizarre qu'il voulait pas
que son papa et
moi soyons là et que il fallait qu'an
soit avec lui tout seul donc là c'était
catégori je disais non et il devenait
très très très très très insistant ouais
donc là ça m'a un peu mis la puce à
l'oreille et j'ai commencé à surveiller
le téléphone de mon gamin et je suis
tombée sur ce message voilà alors euh
donc c'est ça vous êtes tombé sur ce
message et là vous vous êtes dit un ben
là je l'ai appelé tout de suite ouais il
vous a dit quoi il vous a dit quoi ben
je l'ai appelé je lui ai dit que j'avais
découvert le potau rose et surtout que
le le le nom le nom qui apparaît qui est
qui sur le téléphone de mon fils c'était
pas le nom de Bruno Vandelli c'était un
prénom féminin ah ouais d'accord donc il
y avait tout qui était calculé quoi
c'est pas rien oui Kelly non je voulais
j'avais deux questions c'est comment
s'est terminé cette histoire entre ces
deux personnes est-ce que c'est vous qui
avez fait un peu plus fort s'il vous
plaît donc moi j'ai fait partir mon
fil aux États-Unis et Yanis a
pratiquement fait presque une année
scolaire aux
États-Unis il a même il est même je l'ai
même fait
rentrer en école de danse là-bas parce
que le la danse c'était tout pour
c'était sa VI en fait estce qu'il a
réussi de lui-même à se ça a mis du
temps mais moi je quand quand Yanis a
été scolarisé ici à Paris à che
ricodom moi je croyais que je l'avais
complètement éloigné parce que Bruno
avait peur de moi et vous avez appris
hier qu'il c'était pas il voà parce que
brun
m'avait dit qu'il ne le verrait plus
qu'il s'approcherait plus jamais de lui
moi j'avais croisé oui j'avais croisé
Bruno Vandelli à un spectacle d'un ami à
moi qui a une école de danse à anti qui
faisait ces gars là au Palais des
Congrès je peux vous garantir que quand
il m'a vu il s'est caché quoi
ouais truc de fou il a parlé de quoi
Guillaume Janton fait comme s'il était
pas là ah Guillaume Janton bah il a
parlé de plein de trucs je commence à
descendre il paraît que Guillaume de sa
boulimi moi c'est ce qui m'a aussi
beaucoup que tu été boulim ouais ben je
ouais ouais ouais bah ça fait 20 ans 15
ans que j'ai des gros problèmes avec la
nourriture que je fais des crises de
boulimie régulièrement que je prends 20
30 kg que je les repère que je les
reprends et seuls les gens qui sont
boulimique peuvent le comprendre je
pense parce que c'est c'est une vraie
souffrance qui se voit pas dans la vie
mais qui qui est très difficile je vois
que ça vous touche beaucoup mon
témoignage mon
micro le frère de guingan
de St non voilà c'est quelque chose de
de très douloureux et qui est très
chiant à vivre parce que pour moi c'est
une drogue et là où les drogues comme la
cocaïne l'alcool enfin en tout cas
l'alcool est légal mais la cocaïne c'est
illégal la bouffe est partout et c'est
très difficile de de s'en passer quoi
c'est ça qui l'argent aussi vous avez
dit que vous étiez voilà vous étiez
raide
en fait j'ai énormément dépensé à une
période où vous m'avez connu Cyril j'ai
dépensé énormément d'argent c'est vrai
que j'avais bah j'avais deux chauffeurs
j'avais trois appartements parce que
j'avais une vie complètement dissolue
maintenant je peux le dire voilà j'avais
j'avais plein de de relations en même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
temps lourde quelle lourdeur beaucoup
avec Jean-Michel mer et et et voilà je
suis rentré dans une espèce de spirale
de n'importe quoi où j'avais plein de
voitures des appartements je dépensais
10000 € pour un oui pour un non pour
m'acheter des vêtements voilà avenue
Montaigne et en fait je je c'est un
espèce d'engrenage et qui rend très
malheureux et je pense que je suis allé
au bout de ça et j'ai une série de
d'événements négatifs j'ai eu deux deux
contrôles fiscaux qui m'ont qui m'ont
tué enfin professionnellement et et
personnellement et voilà il plein de
choses dans la vie qui sont arrivées qui
ont fait que ça m'a ramené sur terre et
c'est c'est une bonne chose parce qu'
aujourd'hui je m'en fous complètement je
vis beaucoup plus simplement et je pense
être plus heureux qu'avant quoi c'est
fou ce que tu
[Applaudissements]
dis avec moiant mais c'est vrai que
c'est V savait il y a eu ça ouais j'ai
eu ça j'ai eu ça vous fait rire je
Nicolas pernikov mais j'ai perdu un de
mes chiens c'était très dur american
staff et et non et moins drôle j'ai ma
femme qui a fait un AVC il y a 1 an et
ça c'était très dur aussi ça m'a ramené
à la réalité et c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait un enfant avec elle aussi
rapidement aussi parce que c'est vrai
que ça soude ça rapproche quoi et
maintenant tu es plus heureux qu'avant
maintenant tu dépenses plus rien tout ça
non je suis une barre non mais je je
fais plus attention en vrai parce que
parce que parce que parce que c'est vrai
que même moi je le dis au
téléspectateurs oui vous alluciné je me
rappelle je disais mais Guillaume Janton
il a un train de vie c'est un truc de en
fait j'avais l'argent il y a une année
où parce que j'avais un régime
particulier j'ai pas eu d'impôts et une
année blanche en fait j'ai tout flambé
j'ai pas payé mes impôts qui aurait dû
être 50 % alors je vais pas pleur nicher
parce que je voilà je fa pé par Réon
mais euh oui j'ai fait n'importe quoi et
je vivais clairement audessus de mes
moyens et et surtout pour rien pour en
fait je me suis dit mais pourquoi pour
impressionner qui pour faire passer quel
message à qui pour faire le kék et
sortir dans des resto et dans des trucs
et voilà je l'ai fait je le regrette en
partie parce que rappelle les voitures
CIT n'importe quoi voitur tout chauffeur
voilà pas le permis les voyages à New
York à Tokyo pour un oui ou pour un non
mais c'est une manière il a acheté le P
à Toky mais non mais c'est c'est une
manière de dé en fait non à New York en
plus vous étiez pas là ou en plus plusz
pas me rejoindre à New York
tranquillement à l'image en fait voilà
encore une fois j'ai pas envie de faire
pleurer dans les chaumières mais il y
avait une part évidemment de PL plaisir
de kiff mais il y aussi une manière de
se détruire où vraiment je dépensais des
sommes hallucinantes pour desoi genre
quoi bah je sais pas je peux rencontrer
une fille de mois après je lu offrai une
voiture quoi non si bien sûr mais il l'
vu vraiment rencontre quo on dit qu'on
s'est rencontré il y a 2 mois non mais
non mais
voilà je rencontrais une fille à Tokyo
j'allais pour parce que ça me faisait
marrer alors que j'avais déjà et c'est
de ma faute c'est moi qui faisais
n'importe quoi il y a que moi qui suis à
blamé j'allais la voir une fois par mois
à Tokyo et ça me faisait marrer et je
prenais le billet d'avion en première
classe et encore une fois de l'argent
que j' av mais que d'un autre côté je
n'avais pas enfin c'était pas du tout
dans mes moyens de faire
ça et je me suis vraiment détruit avec
ça je pense c'était une manière de se
détruire comme d'autres le font avec la
drogue comme d'autres le font avec
d'autres choses et et moi c'était
dépenser dépenser dépenser et jusqu'à ne
plus avoir rien voilà c'est vra mais
c'est pas grave et je pense que la seule
personne à qui je peux en vouloir c'est
moi encore une fois et pourquoi tu m'as
pas parlé il parle pas a jamais parlé
mais parce que j'ai géré la situation et
quand j'ai plus rien euu c'est là où je
suis retourné viite dans 30 m Carr et je
sais qu'il y a des gens qui vient dans
30 m car même dans moins mais quand on
passe de de de de 500 à à 30 faut
assumer mais j'ai assumé j'étais très
content et j'étais très heureux de Vire
dans 30 m² très heureux voilà très
heureux il pas de problème beaucoup en
plus tuas pas voulu en parler même à ton
pote non même à moi tu vois non parce
que je vais faire quoi demander de
l'argent j'avais pas envie en plus j'
aurais pas donné voilà non mais c'est ça
je pense que non
mais mais
voilà non mais je pense que dans ces
CASL il faut il faut il faut assumer il
faut être un bon homme moi j'ai revendu
toutes mes mondes j'ai revendu beaucoup
de mes fringues j'ai revendu tout ce que
je pourrais revendre j'ai j'ai j'ai
diminué je sais pas par 10 au moins mon
mon train de vie et j'ai la chance
encore de plutôt bien vivre par rapport
au reste des gens donc encore une fois
je m'appitois pas du tout sur mon sort
et dans ces cas-là faut assumer faut
faut stopper net arrêter les conneries
et arrêter de se prendre pour quelqu'un
qu'on n'est pas ouais tu t'es pris
vraiment pour ouais tu es pris pour qui
bah pour un autre ouais j'é j'étais un
avais combien de voitures trois trois ma
copine de l'époque en avait une moi j'en
avais deux et j'avais je bah je
conduisais j' aucune parce que j'avais
pas le permis j'en avais une qui restait
au qui est
énorme pourquoi tu acheté des voitures
tuavais pas le permis pour faire le kék
ouis ouais pour aller au resto j'étais
content je mettais de la musique à fond
j'étais voilà mais c'est après c'est une
sorte de je sais pas peut-être pour se
valider professionnellement socialement
aux yeux de certaines personnes
peut-être vis-à-vis de mes parents
peut-être vis-àvis voilà et aujourd'hui
je m'en fous complètement et je suis
dans le truc inverse plus jamais
j'achèterai une voiture de luxe plus
jamais j'aurai non parce que c'est et en
plus l'argent vendu ta voiture ouais
toutes les voitures je les ai vendu quoi
j'ai vendu à des à des proches non j'ai
vendu une voiture à un proche et et et
voilà et et je je et les deux autres et
quoi les autes je les ai vendu à des des
particuliers et et je pense
particul personne dans vendu ta voure un
proche tu proche il est proche de toi là
quelqu'un qui est proche physiquement là
ah oui ou ça peut être Géraldine ça peut
être vous ça peut être myiam ça peut
être quelqu'un d'autre à la table
pourquoi pas je sais pasen non mais je
ma chien peut-être
non mais
ce Raymon l' à aider Guillaume c'est
pour ça Raymon parce que Raymon c'est
pas du tout ce que il a vraiment voulu
aider Guillaume et ils ont fait un deal
ensemble voilà V pour voilà pour dire la
vérité c'est vrai que j'étais j'étais un
peu dans la merde j'ai demandé d'argent
à personne Raymon il a compris que
j'étais dans la merde et élégamment il
s'est proposé de me racheter une partie
de ma voiture et et je le remercie parce
que il m'a beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup aidé
parce que Guillaume en fait moi j'aurais
pu taper sur lui dire voilà tu as des
pensées j'aime pas les gens qui font ça
vous brûlez l'argent et après vous
pleurez d'abord une il pleure pas il se
plaint pas il assume 30 m² moi ça m'a
fait l'histoire de la voiture ça m'avait
choqué j'ai la nana il la connaît depuis
peu elle a déjà une voiture moi j'ai pas
de voiture elle a déjà une voiture ça
m'avait choqué après on est parti dans
la villa une villa incroyable avec vue
sur la mer il m'a invité je dis mais
comment il peut faire ça et je et je
souviens-toi je lui avais dit fais
attention parce que ça va vite dans le
sens où tu peux gagner de l'argent moi
je suis un crevard ce qu'on appelle un
crevard mais ça va super vite et là ce
que j'aime bien gu c'est que le matin tu
l'appelles à 7h il va dire je pars au
bureau et quand tu l'appes à 22h pour
dire viens on va au resto après
l'émission il me dit B passe on prend
des sandwich je suis au bureau j'étais
déjà au bureau à 7h il est 22h il
retourne après bosser derrière comme
c'est un bosseur il va se relever moi ce
que j'ai pu faire c'est pour récupérer
une voiture pour le coup le
seul pu faire avec des potes aussi on a
pu aussi faire un Gander mais il voula
pas Pasch même pas je vais te dire une
voiture à 50% je l'Auris acheté
c'est
[Musique]
merci pour l'invitation mais au
contraire on veut vraiment nous avoir
toutes les versions et au contraire on
est content que vous soyez là parce que
c'est vrai qu'on veut que vous
rétablissiez votre vérité en 2005 vous
étiez en couple donc avec lonel Team qui
est qui est juste là d'ailleurs
exactement il ça c'est pas le ça c'est
pas on sa pas de mentir làd il est là
merci m pas oh là
là bah pas depuis un moment non jeétais
allé le voir jouer au théâtre il a un
petit bout de temps ah VO ou pas non non
tu en très bon terme bah très bien bien
j'espère que ça va durer il est super
sympa monsur donc vous étiez surtout la
colocataire de Bruno à l'époque oui en
fait moi je louais un appartement et
alors je tiens à revenir sur ce sujet je
n'étais pas propriétaire de
l'appartement et je ne soulouais pas à
Bruno je l'hébergeais et à l'inverse lui
m'avait filé ses clé à can on se
connaitt depuis que j'ai 5 ans ou donc
lui il croyait que vous étiez
propriétaire c'est Lionel team voilà
voilà mais c'était il y a longtemps il a
d oublié c'est pas voilà c'est pas très
grave ça mon Lionel on t'aime quand même
mais je pas avo problème avec le fisque
mon chat tu
vois Yanis il était régulièrement là il
était en couple avec Bruno ou pas à
l'époque oui il venait à la maison ils
étaient en couple ils étaient d'accord
vous avvez l' très heureux d'ailleurs
connaissiez son âge ou pas du tout bah
moi je faisais j'avais l'impression
qu'il avait plus ou moins le même âge
que moi parce que je faisais un peu plus
jeune lui faisait un peu plus vieux je
pense et donc je me suis pas je me suis
jamais posé la question de l'âge très
honnêtement euh vous avez vraiment dit à
à Lionel team de ne pas en parler ou pas
du tout alors je je me souviens pas du
tout avoir dit ça honnêtement j'ai j'ai
bondi devant ma télé quand j'ai vu j'ai
entendu ça parce que j'ai dû lui dire en
effet que sa mère n'était pas pour la
relation mais parfois quand j'avais 25
ans j'ai eu des petits amis mes parents
n'étaient pas pour ses relation là non
plus donc je pense ça na en tout cas
rien à voir avec l'âge que je ne
connaissais pas et qui de toute façon à
l'époque était dans l'âge légal parce
qu'on parle de on parle bien de 2005
ouais c'est ça octobre novembre 2005 oui
voilà donc il avait 16 il il a eu 16 ans
le le 11 novembre 2005 vous avez été en
contact avec Bruno Velli récemment ou
pas du tout 10 minutes ouais 10 minutes
d'accord il conteste toutes ses
accusations alors Bruno reconnaît qu'il
a eu une histoire avec Yanis mais il l'a
jamais violé d'accord donc aujourd'hui
pour vous il s'agit s'agit pas de viol
ni d'agression sexuelle non voilà non
mais simple vous disiez ce soir ah ben
moi je je suis per je serais très déçu
si j'apprenais que je me suis trompée
parce que moi je crois réellement qu'il
y a pas eu ça vraiment je je le crois il
me l'a dit il me l'a dit dans dans le
blanc des yeux je connais l'homme
au-delà de l'artiste je connais l'homme
depuis que j'ai 5 ans c'est comme mon
grand frère je le vois réellement pas
faire ça il y a un énorme battage
médiatique autour de ça qui est en train
de vraiment faire beaucoup de mal à
Bruno et c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité
j'ai accepté l'invitation pas que j'ai
souhaité venir j'aurais préféré venir
pour autre chose bien sûr bah la
prochaine fois P avec plaisir plais donc
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez donc à à
Lionel sur sa version ah bien alors
cette histoire de billet d'avion don je
n ai jamais parlé parce que déjà elle
n'existe pas c'est quoi l'histoire des
billets d'avion je me rappelle plus
billets d'avion pour soisant revenir des
États-Unis d'accord je aurais parlé et
c'est étonnant parce que moi je la
connais pas c de Bill d'avion et j'en ai
parlé à Bruno qui ne la connaît pas non
plus d'accord
euh et puis le fait de de ne pas le fait
de ne pas dire que que qu'ils étaient
ensemble parce que c'est étonnant parce
qu'on allait dans des restaurants dans
le Marais assez branché hyper fréquenter
donc ça en fait ça n'a pas vraiment de
sens de devoir se taire sur une relation
et ensuite d'aller dans le Marais
s'afficher devant tout le monde il y a
d'autres élèves qui sont plein du
comportement de de Bruno euh il parail
il a d'ailleurs été mis à l'écart de sa
propre école de danse à cause de ça-ce
que c'est vrai c'est pas vrai du tout
alors
important que vous le disiez donc c'est
pas vrai c'est lui qui a tenu parce que
il s'est quand même pris un coup hein va
norm c'est quand même un sacré coup
quand on se lève un matin même moi c'est
pas du tout moi qui était concerné quand
j'ai entendu ça ça m'a ça m'a vraiment
attristé pour lui donc il s'est mis à
l'écart et l'école est tenue par
l'équipe pédagogique habituelle et le
centre de danse tourne là à ce moment en
ce moment il doit y avoir des cours à
l'heure actuelle au centre euh oui c'est
pas il doit y avoir il a cours quand ici
la maman de Yanis parle notamment
d'emprise est-ce que de ce que vous en
savez vous avz ce sentiment de vous en
avez évoqué avec Bruno Vandelli ce
rapport peut-être avec cette cette
grande différence d'âge d'emprise moi
j'ai pas l'impression que l'empriseait
un rapport avec une différence d'âge
c'est que pour moi quand on est amoureux
il y a forcément une emprise parce que
moi toutes les personnes dont j'ai pu
tomber amoureuse il a forcément quelque
chose qui me fascinait chez eux donc
quelque part ça c'est une forme
d'emprise amoureuse de Lionel oui tué
fasciné par lui j'étais fasciné par lui
chanteur qu'il était tout ça ouis
toujours forcément sinon on peut pas
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un et donc en
ce sens moi je trouve qu'on utilise le
terme en prise un petit peu on on s'en
sert quoi c'est pas trop le le sujet
juste j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur les
dates parce que donc c'est c'est c'est
parce que c'est le gros point en fait
c'est le grand point oui c'est vrai donc
vous dites qu'il avait 16 ans vous vous
dites qu'il était beaucoup plus jeune en
fait moi je lui ai pas demandé son âge à
l'époque je sais juste que je l'ai vu en
2005 moi dans l'appartement de Pénélope
c'est tout tu l'as vu en novembre il est
né le 11 novembre 8 9 il ait 16 ans non
je l'ai vu moi je pense que après ça
remonte à 20 ans je pense que je l'ai vu
en août septembre donc je sais que à
l'époque pour pour ce que je me rappelle
aû septembre c'est impossible te couper
la parole parce que Bruno fait sa
prérentrée et Bruno n'était jamais à
Paris en
septembre 2 mois de différence 2005 mais
c'était quand même en 2005 donc il mais
ça se joue à 2 mois toute l'histoire
donc pénéope vous qui connaissez bien
Bruno ouion elle nous disait que quand
il les voyait tous les deux Yanis et
Bruno à Paris la relation avait commencé
avant il en était certain alors ça moi
Bruno me l'a jamais dit je ne pense pas
sinon il me l'aurait dit on se racontait
tout mais c'estd j il se connaissait il
était élève chez Bruno ils é après ils
ont développé une forme d'amitié après
moi j'étais pas là tout le temps moi je
ne pense réellement pas je parle en mon
nom je ne pense réellement pas qu'il
soit passé quelque chose avant Bruno m'a
dit que ça a commencé à Paris donc il a
attendu qu'il ait 16 ans et là bim c'est
bon c'est la relation qui commence et
avant il il a attendu parce qu'il est il
est pas idiot d'accord est-ce que vous
avez à dire à P parce que elle est pas
du tout d'accord avec votre version là
alors pour revenir sur les billets
d'avion je n' pas parlé de billets
d'avion moi j'ai jamais dit que c'était
j'ai juste dit que c'était selon Yanis
que c'était Bruno qui lui payit des
billets d'avion moi j'ai juste dit que
Yanis m'avait dit ça je savais pas en
fait s'il venait en train ou en billet
ou en avion donc c'est la seule chose
que je dis autre chose j'ai jamais dit
autre chose euh j'ai juste dit aussi que
tu m'avais dit clairement de ne pas trop
faire de bruit parce que voilà c'était
un petit peu c'est un peu délicat de
voir Bruno avec avec Yanis donc moi je
me vois mal àer donner demander l'âge de
Yanis et et surtout demander à Bruno
quel âge à Yanis à ce moment-là et moi
j'en suis certain l'histoire n'a pas
commencé à Paris jamais de la vie en
fait je vois pas Yanis débarquer dans
l'appart dit ah c'est c'est cool c'est
le nouveau petit ami de de Bruno mais il
se connaissait il se connaissaiit
évidemment il éta élèv en fait voilà
long il connaiss tu peux connaîre des
gens pas oigé pour résumer pour avoir
les deux versions vous votre version
c'est voilà vous c'est quoi votre
version moi ma version elle est très
simple elle bougera pas c'est en
septembre que j'ai rencontré Yanis pour
la première de ma vie dans l'appartement
cours saintamilon et en plus c'est TR
très important c'est que j'ai jamais
donné ton nom je t'ai préservé parce que
je voulais pas du tout parler de toi je
voulais faire attention je voulais moi
je je je veux juste que la
vérité comment qu'il veut
reprendre non c'est pas possible je suis
en mar jeis en mar je suis en et donc
donc j'ai pas parlé de tout ça mais ce
qui était très important c'est que Yanis
m mais tu sais pas tout enfin Yanis à
l'ép tu av du mal à peu drôleoi on on
est d'accord on est d'accord que il
était bien dans ton appartement en 2005
oui mais pas en septembre puisque Bruno
fait sa rentrée déjà c'est fac et vous
pénelope alors est-ce que vous avez un
dernier mot à nous dire
lion je vois pas trop vous dis qu'il
était très pote avec Bruno là ou tu
t'entendais h bien avec Bruno jeisun
coup tu retournes ta veste comme çaour
pas ma veste c'est juste qu' un moment
donné il faut dire la vérité et la vér
tu la connais toi la vérité c'est que
Yanis a été abusé selon
Yanis moi je crois certainement plus
Yanis que
Bruno vous faire une idée également et
c'est bien qu'on a eu la version de
pénéope ce soir merci pénéope ben merci
eu à toi Cyr c'est tout ce que j'ai j'ai
le droit de dire non mais non vous
voulez dire autre chose allez-y B moi je
voulais dire quelque chose parce que
j'ai eu l'avocat de l'avocat de Bruno il
y a pas longtemps et euh il semblerait
que beaucoup de gens sur Paris et sache
une information qui va être divulguée
demain dans les journaux il semblerait
que Yanis a été abusé par quelqu'un
d'autre que Bruno de ses 9 ans à ses 13
ans et étonnemment pourquoi ça ça ne
ressort nulle part et pourquoi il n'a
pas apporté plainte pour ça donc je
voudrais juste savoir et peut-être que
Yanis donne une réponse à ça parce que
là on fait un tafin médiatique autour de
ça avec absolument aucune preuve
d'ailleurs Yanis n'a toujours pas porté
plainte Bruno attend n'attend que ça il
a le dossier qui est
prêt s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
laissz parler là touj pas porter plainte
à l'heure actuelle j'avais au téléphone
il y a encore pas Yanis évidemment il y
a encore une heure et il n'a il n'a pas
porté plainte voilà bah si elle le dit
c'est qu'il a pas porté plainte donc
c'est pas la peine de dire l'avocate va
dire ils ont dit qu' avit porté plinte
on attendra quand il il a dit j'accuse
Bruno de il a pas dit je porte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plainte